moi l'histoire a commencé via les
réseaux sociaux sur Instagram avec mon
compte ostéophélin où j'ai commencé à
parler de sujet tabou féminin sur la
santé féminine pour essayer de lutter
contre les reins médicales à l'approche
du 8 mars journée internationale des
droits des femmes la médiathèque du
canal propose une série d'actions et
d'animation pour célébrer les femmes au
programme quiz blind test et rencontre
avec des auteurs féministes qui
défendent ce qu'on souhaite c'est mettre
en lumière des questions de société
l'engagement le féminisme et puis
accompagner les
usagers les lecteurs le tout public à
réfléchir à se poser des questions à se
rencontrer à discuter la journée s'est
terminée avec l'intervention de deux
autrices féministes venus pour parler de
leurs livres comme Manon le Tournaud
ostéopathe et autrice du livre un corpus
libre qui s'intéresse à la santé
féminine c'est important de parler des
décors des femmes parce que elles ont
besoin de se le réapproprier la société
fait que le corps enfin ce corps féminin
n'appartient pas à chaque femme et donc
ça passe par la connaissance de son
propre corps comment il fonctionne
comment ils dysfonctionne ou encore
Alice du Sutour autrice du livre naître
fille qui raconte les problématiques de
femmes dans d'autres pays du monde par
exemple quand je parle du harcèlement de
rue au Mexique j'avais rencontré des
jeunes filles qui m'avaient dit qu'elle
se reconnaissait vachement qu'elle avait
vécu la même chose pour les participants
c'était l'occasion d'échanger de
débattre sur des sujets autour du
féminisme j'ai vraiment aimé ça c'est ça
regarde nouveau j'ai appris pas mal de
choses je trouve ça génial qui est des
jeunes femmes aujourd'hui qui parle
ouvertement sans savoir peur parce qu'il
faut pas avoir peur prochain rendez-vous
le mercredi 8 mars avec une lecture
théâtralisée du livre une farouche
liberté de la militante féministe Gisèle
Halimi un hommage national lui sera
d'ailleurs rendu par l'Elysée demain
mercredi 8 mars partager justement